Yello bad place what's up dummy
this is Michael the architect from good
place neighborhood one two three five aw
I'm guessing you've been looking for
someone called Eleanor she'll strop
she's here come and get her
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Trevor hi there he is good to see
you again Mikey anything faster brought
you something
Oh nuts Oh
flaming snake ate all the nuts you
brought me too nice to humiliate oh
hello hi you look like a piece of crap
are you Eleanor
dude you're like a legend in the bad
place check this out ah pretty great
right Trevor do you know what caused
this mistake cuz I cannot figure it out
now we're stumped but don't sweat it
champ she's definitely one of ours
so we'll just roll on out and you can
get back to putting rainbows up your
butt or whatever you do here okay
let's hit it sweetheart we got a long
ride what right now Trevor for decency's
sake let her have some goodbyes oh good
people are the worst okay uh thirty
minutes we got to get back for the
bachelor I'm gonna be pissed if I miss
the rose ceremony
oh hey dumb-dumb here there you go no
you must be cheating trying to improve
her bold plan bro Oh actually she
learned a great deal in a very short
about really really I don't care alright
let's hit it
Oh also you should smile more you have
such a pretty smile love you babe can't
wait to torture you
this is the 3:18 to the bad place making
thousands of stops for literally no
reason now you'll notice it's very hot
in here and it will get one degree
hotter every time you think about how
hot it is the just thought about it
you